massacre de butch a été un électrochoc
pour les européens ils doivent prendre
de nouvelles sanctions contre moscou la
présidente de la commission jure sur la
faune der leyen va s'exprimer et elle
propose donc caroline de camaret à une
nouvelle salve cinquième salve de
sanctions contre contre moscou est ce
que on connaît les mesures tout à fait
elle a déjà publié un message vidéo un
communiqué elle va s'exprimer devant le
parlement européen également c'est vrai
que les massacres et les atrocités
commises par l'armée russe abuja ont
fait bouger les lignes dans le camp
occidental et singulièrement dans
l'union européenne
alors que les états unis le canada ont
annoncé de nouvelles sanctions à venir
contre contre moscou paris et berlin ont
décidé dès lundi d'expulser massivement
des des diplomates connecter à
l'espionnage est aujourd'hui la
commission européenne annonce donc une
série de cinquième mesure cinquième rang
de sanctions avec des choses
effectivement très fortes comme ont
désormais on va bannir de l'union
européenne le charbon russe ou fermer
les ports aux navires russes et puis
aussi c'est l'arrêt des importations aux
siens de l'union européenne de certains
marque matériaux très spécifiques et
puis le gel de nouveau et des gardes
proche de vladimir poutine ainsi que
d'entreprises dont deux nouvelles
banques alors si on prend un par un les
pas en avant tout de même emmanuel
macron s'était dit favorable à un
embargo sur le pétrole et sur le charbon
on est déjà d'ores et déjà à l'embargo
sur le charbon et ça veut dire que
l'allemagne et l'italie ont beaucoup
bougé on est dépendant à 46% tout de
même du charbon importé de la russie je
le disais allemagne italie ont bougé
face à la pression de la pologne et des
pays baltes c'est pourtant une
définition et une décision qui n'était
pas simple parce que les pays d'europe
de l'est et l'allemagne dépendent
beaucoup de ce charbon encore lors leur
économie leur mix énergétique est très
charbonné la commission européenne va
aussi proposer je le disais à un embargo
sur des importations pour un montant
estimé à 9 milliards d'euros
diverses importations et interdiction
d'exporter des semi-conducteurs des
machines outils de pointe d'autres
éléments qui seraient destinés à
l'extraction du gaz naturel pour les
russes voilà dix milliards d'euros
bloqués dans l'autre sens aussi on va
interdire l'accès des poids lourds et
bateaux sur le territoire et les eaux de
l'union européenne bateau et poids lourd
russe et puis quatre banques sont
écartés du système swift donc de un
nouveau rang de stations parce que les
européens disaient il faut pouvoir
graduée et là on est arrivé à quelque
chose qui est peut-être un crime de
guerre et qu'il faut marquer assez vite
le coup et le bouquet final ce serait un
embargo sur le gaz russe on n'en est pas
là mais on n'en est pas là parce que
effectivement il ya véritablement
dépendance très forte alors le gaz c est
relié par des pipelines et là on dépend
à 40% du gaz russe c'est beaucoup parce
qu'on ne peut pas le remplacer du jour
au lendemain il faut des importations
massif de gaz naturel liquéfié par
exemple des états unis en train de de
finaliser cela mais là aussi il faut des
terminaux etc c'est beaucoup plus dur à
gérer il ya le stade aussi du pétrole
que souhaite le président français on
lisait 25% de dépendances mais là en
l'occurrence ça toucherait très très
très très durement la hongrie la
slovaquie la république tchèque qui ne
peuvent pas s'en passer du jour au
lendemain donc on est un peu bloquée sur
ces deux chapitres en revanche on sent
bien que les européens sont déterminés
même si ça joue hommage de façon majeure
contre leur propre économie à chaque
fois infliger des rentes de sanctions
quand il estime qu' une ligne rouge a
été passé et ça effectivement pour
vladimir poutine c'est parfois une
surprise et c'est certainement assez
encourageant par pour le président
ukrainien qui continuent à dire
néanmoins que l'union européenne n'en
fait pas assez et on suivra le discours
du président céline ce qui face à l'onu
à 16h merci beaucoup caroline de camaret
pour ces éléments